Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain the 2014 Sci-Fi
short film called “The Real Evidence: Laptop.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie begins with a montage of an office
where many employees are busy in their respective
works.
Some are writing scraps on paper while others
are working on their laptops.
One guy with glasses is also working on his
laptop when his eyes suddenly see something
on the wall near him.
He finds it very unusual, and keeps on looking
at his laptop and the wall, in back and forth
motion.
Astonishingly, the cursor of the laptop mouse
is seen hovering on the wall, out of his laptop
screen.
The guy does not believe his eyes and when
he moves his fingers over the laptop touchpad,
the cursor on the wall moves.
Seeing this, he becomes excited as he has
a smirk on his face.
Then, he looks around to check if any of his
colleagues are seeing it.
The guy thinks of an idea to test if the mouse
cursor has real impacts on the physical environment.
He drags the cursor down from the wall by
controlling the movement through the touchpad.
He then points to the paper cup on his table
and taps the button in the touchpad.
As he does this, the paper cup falls, and
the tea spills all over the table.
It catches the attention of his colleagues.
As they look at him, he apologizes and acts
like he is cleaning the table.
After this successful trial with the paper
cup, he becomes happy.
The guy then looks around and finds another
thing to experiment with the cursor.
He notices a letter on his table and drags
the arrow towards it.
As he hovers it around the letter—the pointer
changes to I-cursor as it comes to text.
The letter is about the request to deduct
the penalty for being late to work.
The guy clicks the cursor to it, deletes the
sentences, writes his boss is a jerk and asks
to add compensation to his monthly fee.
After doing this, he takes the letter in his
hand and starts laughing at it.
As his laugh becomes audible, he finds it
disturbing to the colleagues and stops at
once awkwardly.
He then looks over the letter and smiles.
Following his experiments in the room, the
guy heads out, along with the mysterious laptop
in his hand.
As he strides into the hallway, he sees a
beautiful girl working in the next room.
He sits on the chair in front of her room
from where he can see her.
He then pretends to work on the laptop but
starts peeping at her secretly.
The guy slowly takes the cursor out from the
laptop, down the table towards the room.
While he drags it up her table, she turns
forward to see her papers and the guy gets
his eyes on her skirt.
The devious guy then directs the mouse cursor
inside her dress and clicks the pad.
As he does so, the woman gasps in surprise.
She feels something down below and breathes
slowly.
The guy starts rubbing the mouse pad and peeps
to see her reaction.
The girl begins breathing heavily and loses
control of her body.
She starts moaning after feeling highly erotic
as the guy speeds his rubbing action on the
mouse pad.
She soon rushes to the bathroom while the
guy smiles.
What a simp!
After his shenanigans inside the office, the
guy heads out to his friend, who is talking
to two women.
He asks his friend to come to him because
he has an emergency secret to share.
They go to a rooftop and the guy demonstrates
what he has discovered by editing the board
written as 'Northern Credit Bank' into 'Noobs,
Clowns, and Bastards.'
The friend gets freaked out and asks him to
do something to a nearby parked car.
The guy opens the program and starts reducing
the size of the car until it shrinks into
a toy.
The friend gets super excited and tells him
that he cannot believe what he has found.
He adds that it gives them unlimited opportunities,
and they can do anything with it.
As his friend continues blabbering, the guy
copies a wall of a house and pastes it upon
a window to close it with the wall.
Seeing this, the friend explains that if they
can open any program and make it work like
that in the real world, they can do everything.
He exclaims it to be a teleportation device.
At this point, the guy has started looking
at his friend with uneasy looks.
The friend shares that they can go to a bank
and blackmail the manager into giving them
money, with the threat of destroying the building.
He further adds that after getting the money,
they will destroy the building anyways so
that the manager cannot tell anyone.
After hearing him, the guy has a weird look
on his face which implies that he doesn’t
like his friend’s idea.
Down in the ground, the car’s owner returns
and doesn't find his car.
However, when he looks down, he is shocked
to see a small toy similar to his car in the
spot where he parked.
Meanwhile, the friend gets further ambitious
that they can do anything and no one can stop
them.
He shares that they can reach anyone, and
all the criminals, politicians and policemen
will obey their orders.
The guy now starts getting frightened and
looks over the laptop.
He clicks on the select icon and moves the
mouse cursor to frame the friend's body.
The friend is unknown and keeps saying that
if anyone comes to attack them, they will
ERASE them and solve the problem.
The deranged friend even talks about removing
the army by pressing ‘delete’.
The guy gets taken aback while his friend
sounds like a bomb while demonstrating about
wiping the army.
As the friend faces the guy and raises his
hand to talk, He presses Control + X keys
on the keyboard, which commands to cut the
selected object.
As he does so, the friend's hand gets out
of the selection area of the cursor, and it
detaches from the body while the body vanishes.
The guy gets horrified and sees the event
without his eyes blinking, and hands held
high.
The severed hand falls on top of a car in
the ground with blood spilling out of it.
As the hand thuds and the car starts beeping,
the guy snaps out of the horror.
People immediately gather around the vehicle
and start panicking upon seeing the hand and
blood.
They yell to call the police and the ambulance
as the guy looks down the roof.
Suddenly, the crowd looks at him and tells
him that he is in trouble for what he has
done.
They start calling him crazy and threaten
to call the police.
They also repeatedly ask him to get down from
the roof.
Upon hearing people screaming at him, the
guy starts panicking.
He holds his laptop and opens a program.
The guy then looks down to the ground and
selects the entire area, including the gathered
people and the car.
As the crowd shouts at him, he presses the
Cut command, and the mass, car, hand, and
blood disappear instantly.
The guy looks for them on all sides and gets
surprised himself.
As he becomes breathless, he folds his laptop
and realizes what he has done.
After wreaking havoc in his workplace, the
guy hits the road and starts moving ahead.
He has his bag to his side, and the laptop
held to his hand.
As he walks, he looks in a hurry and continues
seeing back and forth.
Soon, a car comes from the opposite direction.
The guy shows his hand and asks to stop the
vehicle.
He tells the driver that he wants to go to
the Kremlin with urgency.
The driver denies him and tells him that the
traffic is awful there and they will get stuck
for a long time.
The guy pleads that he will provide the driver
with any money he demands, but he drives away
with an apology.
As the driver moves ahead, the guy tries opening
his laptop.
He soon closes it as the vehicle goes out
of his sight.
In the final scene, the guy keeps walking
forward and approaches a large building.
As he looks here and there, he discovers a
large mouse arrow hovering in the building
wall.
He gets frightened and looks on all sides
to find nothing.
As he tries to move ahead, he sees the cursor
arrow on the road, pointing towards him.
The guy starts panting and gets worried.
As he slowly takes some step back, the cursor
moves towards him and covers him totally.
As he looks towards the sky, the cursor clicks
and he is squashed on the ground, and blood
is splattered all over.
This suggests that someone else possesses
the magical power too.
After finishing him off, the cursor starts
moving and goes out of frame.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.